[Applaudissements]
oui on installe alors l'aja là n'ont pas
tout de suite avec la lorie vient
d'acheter lorient on dirait qu'elle un
défilé ici alors loris tu vas essayer de
bluffer d'accord ou ou bien tu as tu vas
dire ce que tu bois et mettez vous
d'accord mettez vous d'accord sur les
deux d'accord on enverra celui qui
attend jeu par un ordinateur tout comme
ça vous allez voir troisième kabila blog
je sais ce qui est à moi derrière
faisons nous faisons le comme ça bouge
quand il regarde regarde ce qu'il
regarde regarde ce qu'il a fait fort tu
vas nous dire ce que tu vois
lorie ou alors il va si je les regarde
avec toi donc avec toi les gens qui
arrivent à ce moment là c'est bizarre
mais bon ça
alors oui on s'est pas mis d'accord
baby drucker elle a ouvert alors je vous
explique le principe il y a quelque
chose quelqu'un dans cette cabine qui va
bluffer qui dit la vérité qu est que
s'ouvrent aux femmes honneur aux femmes
des îlots qu'est ce que vous avez
je sais que c'était horrible c'était
quoi j'ai vu mike tyson
mike tyson dans la cabine comment en
string mike tyson of kings fonctions
possibles quand même
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mike tyson
on sait jamais c'est peut-être associe
non mais c'est vrai ces plaies d'un
sosie bako moi j'ai vu celle qu'on avait
envie de claquer quand on était gamins à
la télé nellie oleson de la petite
maison dans la prairie
mais en modèle qu'elle tombe pas dans la
colline allez debout elle est en suède
avec la même truc de l'époque
alors quoi faut que je sois crédible si
na li à temps il ya ma le père qui
clique du bois ouais y'a pas la petite
qui tombe tout le temps mais en mode lan
il est en pleine promo pour le film
attention qu'ils avaient pensé à ce
détail
voilà je vais juste vous demander qui
dit laurie et jean michel maire
apparemment il vous fait chaud team
d'innover personnes choisies du corps
est à moi je dis laurie dit chlorine
pourquoi ce qu'elle attend cependant une
surprise quoique quoique wayne rice
jamais vous êtes nous être terrible en
ce moment je suis sûr qu'elle est la
meilleure salle autant d'enfants
absolument et lui connais toutes les
dates dont on aime les hommes choisis
donc y en a qu audi mike tyson un débat
on va regarder tout de suite je
regardais qu'il ya il y à des lieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attendez à lui a donné le point